d'accord
hawaï guy saint cyr est un guide
touristique hors norme
au caire à bord de ce bateau de pêche il
embarque près d'une dizaine de touristes
français elle est montée douce à
l'échelle
brossac vous le mettez dans laquelle est
gardée avec vous votre anorak et aux
appareils photo c'est tout
là on va être mouillé ça bombarde un peu
comme
si l'on traversé la planète ce n'est pas
pour les prendre en photo des baleines
ou pour goûter aux eaux chaudes du
pacifique
d'ailleurs ici il serait malvenu de
tremper ses orteils
derrière cette épaisse fumée un
spectacle unique au monde
regarde alors
ou là mais on sent les chaleurs
jusqu'ici très bas
un torrent de lave en fusion à 1200
degrés vient terminer sa course dans
l'océan
regard et tout est là que vous voyez là
parcouru à peu près 15 km à partir du
lac de la zup ou jusqu'ici et en 15 km
et l'a perdu à peu près 50 degrés
maximum là on s'approche tour et vabres
et non les candidats
moi je suis subjugué
vous avez déjà vu de la lave à la télé
ou
oui à la
télévision
il ya tout ce qu'il faut
notre crainte de vendre et de l'ordre
ce spécialiste français des volcans
promène ses clients sur les cratères les
plus actifs du globe
et pour leur offrir des sensations
fortes il a plus d'un tour dans son sac
je note abolition de la coulée
que si on veut y retourner pour attirer
avec le gps
l'idéal c'est d'arriver pas la terre et
s'approcher des coûts et retrouver un
passage pour défendre là dedans
ça vaut pour after un peu dangereux non
on verra on verra sur le moment
à la nuit tombée le spectacle laisse
sans voix il n'imagine pas que dans
quelques jours à peine ils vont vivre
ici une expérience qui les marquera à
jamais
le tourisme des volcans c'est le genre
de voyages extrêmes qui se développent
actuellement en europe on connaît
surtout les deux stars italiennes l'etna
et le stromboli
parmi les 40 volts en activité les plus
visités sont en indonésie
ou en ethiopie
mais le plus grand spectacle se situe à
18 heures d'avion de paris à l'ouest de
la californie sur l'archipel d'hawaï
il fait partie des états unis d'ailleurs
leur président obama y est né
le lieu est surtout connue pour ses
plages qui font rêver la terre entière
comme waikiki et ses vagues qui attire
des millions de touristes depuis un
siècle
l'île des volcans la plus au sud est
aussi la plus grande d'ailleurs on
l'appelle big island
ici peu de plages ou avec un sable noir
qui n'invitent pas à poser sa serviette
et au milieu des nuages gris omniprésent
des volcans dont les plus vieux culmine
à plus de 4200 mètres d'altitude et
parfois se réveille
[Applaudissements]
depuis 30 ans lille est régulièrement
secoué par des éruptions
des maisons parfois englouti par des
coulées de lave
chaque année près d'une dizaine de
touristes qui s'avance un peu trop près
périssent brûlés ou asphyxiés par les
fumées toxiques
[Musique]
mais il en faut plus pour effrayer nos
aventuriers français
à gauche
c'est tout à fait au fond nicole et son
mari laurent ont quitté leur maison à
saint-etienne il y a trois semaines
à 72 ans elle est une ancienne prof de
biologie
lui 77 ans est un pédiatre à la retraite
ce ne sont pas de grands sportifs et
chaussures de montagne jusqu'à lors leur
expérience des volcans se limiter à
l'auvergne ou une balade en italie sur
les pentes du stromboli
mais pour leurs 50 ans de mariage nicole
a offert à son mari la réalisation d'un
rêve de gosse un tour du monde des
volcans un mois tout compris pour 10000
euros chacun de quoi ça sert de masque à
gaz ça sert pour éviter de respirer les
valeurs souffraient et d'irriter no no
de notre appareil respiratoire
oui bien sûr tout sans desservir vanuatu
depuis le début de leur périple ils ont
déjà vu une dizaines de cratères c'est
différent
en indonésie
en nouvelle zélande puis après à hawaï
ce seront les cas l'appa gosse il ya
deux jours à peine il était plus au sud
au vanuatu sur les pentes d'un volcan
très explosif on l'a fait tout au jutra
terre ait
eu des explosions qui est fait est fait
ces violences ont fait des bonds qui
sont partis un petit peu d'ailleurs
pas loin de où on n'est pas loin des
bombes des banques
et on avait comme consignes surtout ne
bougez pas parce que les gens ont
tendance à courir pour les éviter en
fait il faut rester sur place les
regarder ou d'autres comme chercher
frissons alors un petit peu petit peu
oui
hawaï est le point d'orgue de leur
voyage le seul endroit où la lave est
aussi visible mais pour l'approcher le
lendemain ils vont devoir jouer les hors
la loi
leur cible ce cratère il s'est réveillé
il y a cinq ans son activité scrutés en
permanence
par cet observatoire
dans la journée les rangers ce veille à
en interdire l'accès impossible de voir
le magma d'ici
à moins d'attendre la tombée de la nuit
[Musique]
il est 23h30 guy l'organisateur de ce
périple sonne le rappel des troupes
une limpidité le masque à gaz
et vous allez à mener 2 0
[Musique]
il est le seul sur libre à proposer ce
genre d'expédition
une petite route tranquille on laisse la
voiture et après on y va
à 72 ans ce lyonnais passe les trois
quarts de l'année à faire découvrir les
volcans aux touristes
[Musique]
hawaï pour accéder au périmètre interdit
il vaut mieux sortir la nuit les
patrouilles de police se font plus rares
au fil des ans qui a mis au point une
stratégie pour ne pas se faire repérer
bonjour je vous rappelle je vous
rappelle encore une fois de bien
désactiver les flashs des appareils
photos
d'accord ce qu'on sera pile en face
d'observatoire il y à plus d'une heure
de marche jusqu'au cratère ils
avanceront dans le noir total en évitant
les rassemblements pour ne pas attirer
l'attention victoire donc on va marcher
tranquillement je suis devant et chacun
est séparé de 30 mètres
l'aqua n'essayez pas de discuter à 2 de
rester là un côté l'autre non trente
mètres un peu être un fait
d'accord et on s'appelle pas encre il
pas tranquille à
l'e3 l' écoute reste où tu es tu vas
voir je vais te dire levé depuis 7
heures du matin nicolas bien du mal à se
mettre dans la peau d'un commando des
forces spéciales ça fait beaucoup 30 m à
tpv
au loin seul le volcan est clair la nuit
[Applaudissements]
le risque c'est qu'à l'arrivée les
vapeurs empêche toute visibilité sur le
lac de lave
c'est ce qui est arrivé à guy un mois
plus tôt avec un précédent groupe
mais cette fois la chance de leur côté
de la madone noir mais doucement
fait d'y appareil avec itunes
nishi
attention vous est ébloui par la rrq
faites attention il ya des cailloux
devant roule un but et pas longtemps ils
en ont rêvé mais au bord du précipice la
peur du danger les retient qu'un instant
view
vient l'avait amené à areva
[Musique]
en contrebas une marmite bouillonnante
de magma
et des vagues de feu qui viennent ranger
petit à petit la falaise
oui voilà voilà
tancrède t'aurais fait réagir ça te quoi
ya pas de conclure assez forts pour dire
ce qu'il pense
sèche
mais muet lors de ce spectacle pareil on
peut aller voir un petit peu plus loin
d'avoir vous verrez il ya des failles il
faut faire gaffe
mais ici on est relativement tranquille
rêverie ne cherchons pas le dis à
envoyer les caméras
si ses clients le sustt aveuglément
c'est parce que guy st cyr est avant
tout un géologue de formation
après ses études il ya 40 ans il aurait
pu rester travailler tranquillement dans
un laboratoire comme le font la plupart
des vulcanologues mais il a préféré
monter son agence de voyage avec sa
femme est ainsi passé sa vie à approcher
un maximum de volcans
bonbons noir c'est de partager avec les
gens vous avez vu leurs émotions quand
ils arrivent ici ils sont ils en ont
plein les yeux mais moi je suis comme ça
fait ça fait celui ci depuis qu'il
aidait depuis cinq ans j'ai de dire ici
25 30 fois mais c'est jamais pareil j'ai
toujours le même bonheur toujours
et c'est vibre quand ça bouge tout le
temps chaque fois vous venez le voir il
est différent
c'est comme une femme en fait c'est un
peu comme une femme
donc un caractère un peu difficile
le coup de foudre il a eu à 18 ans en
italie donc on va arriver en voiture ak
la pana aujourd'hui et dit avoir retenu
la leçon même si parfois pour épater ses
clients il continue de jouer avec le feu
comme ça j'ai prise j'ai pris un steak
pour le fait cuire sur la c'est ce que
j'appelle le steak au fil de fer je
passe le fil de fer dans le steak je le
retourne je pose mon steak sur la couler
on avance avec la cool et on retourne
c'est cuit impeccable voilà c'est beau
et on mange au mangent deux steaks
directement devant la coulée
avant d'entraîner ses clients griller
des steaks sur le spot le plus chaud de
lille give les mettre en garde sur les
dangers de cette aventure
le lendemain le convoi se rend à
quelques kilomètres du volcan
dans une zone autrefois dévasté par des
coulées de lave
il en reste des traces des tunnels
qu'elle a creusé celui-ci le plus long
du monde 60 km
ici cela fait 200 ans que la lave ne
passe plus mais demain ils marcheront
juste au dessus d'un autre tunnel lui
remplit cette fois de magma il faudra
faire attention où l'on met les pieds le
sol sera très mince par endroit
qui s'appelle l'eau
non ces préfets il peut y avoir un mètre
cinquante centimètres au dessus de leur
tête les racines des arbres ont traversé
la croûte qui fait moins d'un mètre
d'épaisseur
le plafond de la grotte menace à tout
moment de s'effondrer
nos traversées assez rapidement nicole
et laurent n'écoute pas les consignes
trop occupé à réaliser leur film de
vacances
allaient rester pas trop ici ray
après 1h30 de marche
la leçon est comprise
attention
nous regarder nous la petite bande a
pris conscience du danger qui l'attend
vous allez imaginer sur quoi vous avez
marché demain
c'est bien de confort de 50 centimes et
enfin sinon il peut y avoir en mettre 2
m 3 m bien que y avoir 20 cm aussi ouais
ça peut être très très minces laurent
l'intérieur sinon cela pas davantage et
terrorisé en pensant que de ses billets
vous auriez terrorisé parce que vous
fait pas n'importe quoi
le lendemain l'ultime étape de leur
périple à hawaï ne va pas se passer
comme dit l'espérer
[Musique]
il a prévu de les emmener au pied de ses
cascades de l'avs une nouvelle excursion
de nuit mais cette fois le chemin sera
bien plus long et difficile
sur leur route des coulées de lave
apparaissent ici et là
[Musique]
à quelques kilomètres du site le plus
dangereux les rangers américains montent
la garde
[Musique]
et
il ya des vapeurs toxiques dans le coin
vous ne pouvez pas aller plus loin
deux semaines plus tôt un couple de
touristes australiens qui s'est aventuré
trop près des cascades a été pris dans
ces vapeurs d'acide le mari a été
retrouvé mort asphyxié
mais pas question pour guillet sa troupe
de se laisser stopper si près du but
[Musique]
de nouveaux clandestinement les voilà
partis pour deux heures de marche
le terrain est irrégulier
fruits frais de crevasses
le vent a tourné dans la nuit éloignant
les fumées nocives
mais au cas où dix préfèrent ne pas
tenter le diable
bon il ya un côté
toujours anticiper toujours être prêt
parce que lorsque les gaz arrive là on a
tendance à s'affoler tout de suite et
c'est vrai que c'est désagréable à
respirer et on habite fait s'affoler
donc un vrai business
savoir news la
voilà
tu vas mais qu'il est à l'envers
au fur et à mesure qu'ils s'approchent
des cascades de l'avs la température
monte au sol on dépasse les 200 degrés
si l'on reste immobile les semelles
fonde tout brûler afin de tout
juste sous nos pieds des tunnels de
magma de plus de 1300 degrés
seuls quelques centimètres nous séparent
de la roche en fusion
on va pouvoir faire des sectes avons
regardé
et yan tu vois alors dis-moi ce que tu
en penses qu'à ta voiture et
bienvenue
à l'or noir
[Rires]
le club kabyle scola matin il n'y a pas
le feu regarde d'abord
le spectacle et hypnotique mais guy
reste vigilant sur ce terrain où le
danger peut surgir à tout instant
ouais t'as bn peut-être rien du tout
rire derrière là à quelques mètres de
nous des coulées apparaissent subitement
l'ambiance n'est plus à l'extase des
premiers jours cette lave que tous rêvé
d'approcher les terrorise
la cuisson du steak sur la lave ce sera
donc pour une prochaine fois pourquoi
rester pas plus longtemps non il bat en
retraite que je suis pas rassuré
te dire
c'est super mais c'est très chaud et moi
j'arrive pas un jeu
comment dire le savoir au dessus de la
lave est assise à une distance aussi
courte y en avoir jusqu'à brutale
angoisse
avant de rentrer seul guy ira un peu
plus loin pour s'offrir un dernier coup
de chaud cette fois pratiquement au
contact de la la
quelques pas au milieu d'un barbecue
géant
guy a formé son fils au même métier que
lui mais après un demi-siècle passé sur
les volcans le vieux briscard n'est pas
encore prêt à passer le flambeau
moi si je vois plus sale jeu mort je
mords
j'ai besoin de ça pour une
salle bain
épuisés ils mettront trois heures avant
de rentrer à bon port
jusqu'à aujourd'hui vingt mille
touristes ont marché dans les pas de guy
st cyr